okay everybody thumbs up welcome clap it
up welcome back to ass animal super
squad the greatest game of all time
which I made completely by myself I'm
taking all the credit for all the work
that has been done why not just keep
playing this ten out of ten game of all
time
critics are calling this the greatest a
compliment accomplishment in humankind
and I would have to quit god damn it
oh I'm fine how about that there's many
possibilities in this game endless
posture there's a map day there we go
just need the right speed and momentum
there it is there it is we got it what
is this jumpy jumpy there's just so many
ways to go in the game look at that
beautiful look at that front flip I did
it
and we're back up on top as we always
are come on little puffer you can do
this damn it he is getting his ass beat
Oh No here we are Wow
we're fine we're absolutely fine poor
low puffer you didn't do nothing all
right thank God a checkpoint I'm fine I
don't think I'm supposed to go there
okay whatever
god damn it already okay I get I got to
stand on the platform my goal is to be
jacksepticeye if I beat his score then I
know I have done a great job oh my god I
think I'm okay alright another
checkpoint nice yeah you know I might be
a little biased but these levels are
well-designed men
look at that okay we're going up to the
top Hey look at that great come on I
gotta be jexif to camp
I'm gonna check what score he guys later
[ __ ] that's annoying why does that keep
happening alright let's take a nice easy
as an easy you got a timing
you got a touch you got a time it you
got it you got a timing you got a timing
for real how long did Jack take various
there it is
he's there in two minutes 18 I'm there
oh no I got a beat Jack that's all I
care about now if I don't then this game
has been for nothing
I did it I did it whoa what the heck
what is this
how does this even work no oh we charges
I see I see you hold it down oh look at
that
I knew about that I knew about that I
knew about that as well
I knew about everything because I made
everything in the game let's get the
checkpoint charge it baby come on
maybe too much power maybe not
god damn it come on out enough time to
fail come on come on come on come on
there's a flame there there's a flame
there everybody look at that look at it
perfection
let's get the perfection everybody all
right then we go down we go yes come on
[Applause]
come on the game the levels are getting
a lot harder doc come on I gotta be Jack
I gotta be Jack I gotta be Jack come on
come on come on come on come on yes
that's an unlock you know what I need
the hovercraft come on here we go here
we go here we go come on
yes yes yes what no you asked us okay
5:46 well well well I bet I bet you know
he didn't even beat the Louisville five
five eleven what the hell I thought he
was family friendly Christian I'd learn
to just click there and that's what you
said Jack 550 far you got your base
money Jack I didn't even try I didn't
even try moving on oh there's a star
level jumpy jumpy oh that's the thing we
unlocked okay let's try it
what didn't then what I need to get oh
it's like a I need to I need to jump on
the thing - are you kidding me - how now
I need to go back a little bit
well that's impossible
oh I know how I know how oh I get it
just ignore that was easy
that was easy we got corn dog everybody
let's go to crystal and pipes come on
come on easy I gotta be Jake again man I
got so much bag look at that speed
go home you Irish something bad okay yes
look at it I'm pumping the speed I'm
pumping the speed the hell are you
smoking jacket what happened to you you
fell up you fell off Jack why am I so
mean to Jack at him I have no reason to
okay you know why I'm starting toward a
drama for the sake of promoting this
game wow I really did it guys I really
man I can't see where I'm going I'm sure
it's I'm here now I'm here now
[Music]
nailed it no no no no miss no no no oh
yes this machine is the best dude there
it is yes we really went for realistic
physics you can tell right it's so nice
here we go look at that boy look at this
boys easy excuse me excuse me can the
game be a little more easy what's
happening okay right you know what I'm
gonna bet my youtube channel oh you
thought you could make me fall down I'm
gonna bet my youtube channel I'm beating
Jack in this game and I'm not even
trying get me out there it is ladies and
I go hey look at that that's awesome
very nice 219 what did Jack get three
years
the air and wave them like you just
don't care
3:55 well I think we know who the casual
is I want to play some of you guys maps
these are my maps
I sort by likes jungle escape got a lot
of likes so let's go with that one let's
see what you guys have made in the game
it's actually decent looking man it's
like well-designed and everything wow
it's almost like you guys have some form
of talent I'm really impressed you guys
made this oh look at that it's got a
different option oh my God look at that
get the checkpoint and a front-flip
thank you wow I really misjudged you
guys I did I thought you would make
really bad levels bidding these aren't
up oh wow oh wow oh wow oh oh my god
this is awesome okay here Brad not again
[Music]
what is happening whoa whoa nope no no
no too fast too fast
oh my Oh No
ever again we did that was awesome that
was so cool
I gotta like that one I got unlike that
one man Supremes rollercoaster zero
deaths I'll be the judge of that
[Applause]
what the heck what is this vehicle oh
wow
hey come up come up come on give me the
speed mr. puffer wait what's happening
oh my god oh my god I'm fine I'm fine
ow nice nice I do that on purpose
look at this oh [ __ ] we've burned up ok
we're almost there
we're almost there don't worry we're
gonna make it to the top no no no it's
fine I'll make it to the top don't worry
about don't worry about it don't worry
about it don't worry about it ok shut up
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
don't worry about me
this game is clearly [ __ ] this game
has given up on me how that what we're
fine we're fine we're fine
I missed the checkpoint are you kidding
me fifty meters 50 meters I just need to
go 50 meters how and then we're done
okay come on come on just put me down
just put me down here please
oh no we're still here come on just ten
meters
alright we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine I actually did it rake up
gaming well done designing that level I
really enjoyed it very hard level four
very hard whamon I'll be the judge of
that
all right what do we got huh what did we
get huh all right what did we get very
easy level four very tough man it's what
I'm getting in I'm you know I'm not even
gonna get the checkpoint cuz I know I
don't need oh my god oh wow wow wow it's
fun oh wait it's the boat thing again no
wait what I'll jump over any day son
this machine is Opie nerf nerf this one
you guys thought you could give me a
challenge please you guys are a bunch of
wimps
come on seriously guys if you want to
make a hard level all you have to do was
ask ow
that's fine happens to everyone that's
fine that happens to everyone
there's two speed skip the checkpoint no
problem
look at the speed speed and momentum
baby okay I did that on purpose
oh no oh we're fine we're a little move
not adjusted properly but we're fine
okay the arrow says this way and the
arrow didn't mine oh my god what in the
world oh my god what how long is this
level dude oh oh wow ah damn it
there it is like a marinated sauce
that's been marinated look at that this
is no sauce no ketchup just sauce okay
we're here now I don't know if I'm
supposed to be okay you know what the
level got a little harder I'll give you
that but that is this is my first try
after all so I really appreciate all you
got to land on the coop [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yep oh it's fine I don't I don't need
two propellers no damn it you guys are a
bunch of wham and disrespect her I knew
it I knew it since the beginning says I
knew it was a bad idea to like you guys
make the levels I knew it was a bad [ __ ]
oh no are you kidding me if you want to
get good at this game you got it you
gotta at least respect five times a day
easy no Felix go back to the cloud go
back to the cloud Kingdom there we go
remember the key speed
is weed [ __ ] I think I'm not gonna make
it
I think I'm not gonna make it and that's
really [ __ ] annoying get the other
clown get the other clown oh yes yes
it's all thank God okay all right it's
happening
there it is oh wow this game is so hard
guys wow so hard
you really did me a challenge I am so
scared come on here we go damn it there
it is like a marinated sauce that's been
sauced am i right ladies you know what
I'm talking about ladies the whamon all
five of you that watch this channel
really appreciate you talking yes
look at that scale the Swedish man skill
good someone to do a mountain climbing
map with this but this one that'd be
funny
no I flew past the goal that's a fake
goal isn't it oh that's a fun level I
enjoyed that
Christian Channel everyone
well what what's happening I need to go
down what happened to gravity man wow
what a great level Cristen channel
everyone in credit wait the goal is in
the middle I see it I see it oh wow oh
oh that's the trick that's Oh No
yeah we can do we can we can do it [ __ ]
Hey look at that Christine channel
everyone created level you know what sir
siren you get a life I just really want
to thank you guys for all the support on
the game so far it really means to live
it's a super fun game I think you guys
are really gonna like it it's so fun to
see especially the character creations I
want to play more of your levels so
please go ahead and make some make some
challenging one and see if you can beat
me with the timing on them which I know
you can't because I know you're all a
bunch of lowlife level scumbags who
don't know how to play video games
I'll leave a link to the description if
you want to check out the game any
support is highly appreciated the game
is still in early access we're gonna add
more and more and more but it already
has so much all the positive reviews
thank you to everyone that left a review
on the steam page as well for taking the
time and do that I really have thought a
lot and just sharing the good world of
ass which is always ass Thank You
jacksepticeye and all the other
youtubers that play the game as well so
far even though you are god-awful at the
game you know it's okay you can't be you
can't beat me you just can't but at
least you trying oh that's cute that is
a big-ass checkpoint boy oh hell yeah
I'm bouncing haha sorry let me just
finish his level
[Music]
hey that's awesome
all right thank you guys I'm leaving
like I'll see you in the next one
goodbye squad fam